The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HUGH MCMANUS: Welcome to
the Variability Simulation.
This should look
kind of familiar.
This is a much simpler
simulation than before.
It's not going to
take all day, but it's
going to illustrate one
point very well, which
is what's the impact
of variability
on process performance?
That's our learning
objective and we're
going to look at it through
the poker chip simulation.
We're going to look at
a computer simulation
because one of the
problems with variability
is sometimes to understand
a variable system,
you need a lot of
data, a lot of cases.
And we're also going to explore
some simple relationships that
help us, including that
cue-theory equation that Earll
showed, to help us understand
variable processes.
This is a piece of a rather
old data on an engineering
process with high variability.
The traditional
process shown here
a the high cycle time
and high variability
was actually the process
that was value stream mapped
in the module we
showed, I believe
it was two rays ago, that had
that very messy value stream
map with all the arrows
going everywhere.
It was a very
unpredictable process.
It ended up having
very high variability.
Now, the problem
with that, given
that that process was embedded
in a larger process, which
was to produce an airplane, it
was just the drawing release
process.
The problem wasn't
even so much the fact
that it took a long time,
although that wasn't great.
The problem was that the
variability was almost as high
as the actual time, which means
it could take almost no time,
it could take double
the amount of time.
And how easy is it
to do organized work
in an environment where even the
allegedly simple processes are
so unpredictable?
It's very bad.
Now, they managed to
actually do a lot about that
by applying Lean,
but you can see
how disruptive that high
variability is going to be.
The accounts payable module
also reinforced that,
that the high
variability was very
destructive to that process.
On top of that, you're going
to have quality problems
with a variable process.
That's highly likely.
They may be variable
because of mistakes,
or it may be that the variable
process makes it easier
to make mistakes.
And then we're
also going to talk,
both in Six Sigma and today,
about the process capability
being affected by variability.
So we're going to do, I said
this already, a dice game.
We're going to do a
computer sim and we're
going to look at some
simple relationships.
We're also going to
sort of foreshadow
some stuff we're going to do
in the Quality and Six Sigma.
Not on these bullets--
I'm talking fast
right now because I'm
going to try to carve
out a little bit of time
at the end to discuss
some of the things
you can do about
variability because I
think that's particularly
important to our health care
audience.
To some extent, our engineers,
but particularly our health
care people.
One of the big
issues with applying
any kind of process improvement
in a very high variability
environment is just
getting your mind
wrapped around what does
an average mean, what
does even a standard
deviation mean in a process
where the variability
has weird distributions
and odd special
cases and outliers?
We'll try to carve out
a little bit of time
to actually talk about some
of the practical things
you can do to get
variability under control.
Here's a perfect system.
What you are sitting
in front of is
a perfect, balanced,
single-piece flow
system, or near single.
It's a very small-batch system.
It has tasks arranged
in order in, actually,
a U-shaped shaped cell.
It's not a pull cell,
it's more of a push cell,
but still, it's a U-shaped cell.
Every task has an inventory in
front of it, a little buffer
inventory to make sure
that it has the things it
needs to do to do its work.
Every task is
perfectly balanced,
so there's no bottlenecks
in the system.
The only thing imperfect about
the system is its variability.
And this half of
the room, your mats
actually say mailroom
and PFR check and, well,
you get the picture.
We're looking at the accounts
payable process here.
You guys on the health
care side actually
have familiar-looking
mats from yesterday
because you had a
process that had
variability issues yesterday.
The point here, both sides
of the room are identical.
And the point we're
actually trying to make here
is an awful lot of
processes look like this.
Even if you get them perfect, if
they have variability in them,
they're going to behave in
ways that are actually even
worse than one might expect.
So let's find out how
this system behaves.
This is the game.
It's a very simple game.
What we're going to ask
you to do is every day--
we're going to call
the shifts day--
we are going to process chips.
We are going to process one
six-sided die worth of chips,
so anywhere from
one to six chips.
There's our variability.
The way we are going
to process them is we
are going to pick up
chips from our inbox.
If you are the customer
or patient person,
you have a big pile
of chips, so you have
an infinite quantity of chips.
Just pick up chips from there.
Everybody else has
a finite number
of chips that they can pick
up, the ones in their inbox.
So you will be rolling a dice,
picking up that number of chips
from your inbox.
If you don't have
enough, OK, too bad.
If you roll a 6
and you only have
three, which is what
everybody has now,
then you just pick up the three.
And then everybody at the
same time, to avoid confusion,
passes those chips,
the number of chips
that they can pass, to
the next person in line.
And then at the
end of each day, we
will write down how
many chips we passed.
The only tricky part about that
is that both the archive here
and the discharge
there, a certain number
of chips every day
will go into that mat,
and the customers
or the patients
have to record that number.
That's kind of the overall
throughput of the system.
So that's a slight
trickiness at the end.
That's what we're going to do.
So for example, here's day one.
Everybody has three chips.
If this person rolls a 3,
they pick up all three chips,
send them along.
This person rolls a 2, they
can only pick up two chips.
This person rolls a 5, they
can only pick up three chips
because that's all they have.
No waiting for this person
to send the two along,
so then you have five--
no, that's cheating.
The chips only get passed
one station per day.
This person rolls
a 1, et cetera.
This person rolls a 6, they only
had three, so they pass three.
And then this is what it looks
like at the end of that day.
Three have been
passed along, two out,
so the inventory went up.
Three came out, two went in,
so that went down a little bit.
Three went in, only one
left, so that's got more.
Let's see, one went
in and three came out,
so that person only has one.
The overall throughput
of the system was three.
We're going to record how many
did you do, how many did you
pass along?
So either your die roll
or how many you had,
whatever number is smaller.
How many did you pass along?
And then at the
end of the round,
what is your work in progress?
So everyone starts with three,
so that number is already
filled in.
At the end of each day, you're
going to record your number.
Yeah, so here's an example.
Our person there passed one job
along and some work built up,
so at the end of that day,
they had five, et cetera.
The customer or
patient worksheet
is a little bit more
complicated because they're
sending the work out.
That's basically always going
to be the die roll because you
have lots and lots of chips.
You're going to record the
number of jobs that actually
came through the system,
and here, the U-shaped cell
is going to help us.
So the number of
jobs that are added--
not in, but added-- to the
finished pile at each round
is recorded here.
And then you're
also going to keep
track of the total WIP on the
whole table, the total work
in progress in the whole
table, which starts at 12.
Now, you could just
count every time,
but that would be really
slow, so instead, we're
going to use a conservation law.
Earll's an old aerodynamicist,
so they love conservation laws,
right?
A former, a retired
aerodynamicist.
A former aerodynamicist.
They love conservation laws.
This is the conservation
of chips laws.
If you know that you sent out
six and three got finished,
then three must have
gone into the system.
And they didn't fall on the
floor or get eaten or anything,
so this number must
have gone up by three.
So there's a little
equation there
that will help you figure
out the new work in progress.
So everybody think they
can do that much math?
And I think that's actually
written on your sheet,
so you should be
able to do that.
OK, and there's an example.
If three go in and three
come out, it stays the same.
If two go in and one comes
out, then that extra chip
must be sitting on the
table, so it goes up by one.
And we can keep doing
that ad infinitum.
OK, what do we
think should happen?
AUDIENCE: Maybe we should just
ask if there are any questions.
HUGH MCMANUS: Any questions
about the process?
AUDIENCE: So I [INAUDIBLE]
and I roll the die,
and I get like, 5.
So I pass on three because
I only have three chips.
HUGH MCMANUS: Because you only
have the three, that's right.
AUDIENCE: So under
patients completed,
I'll have three there?
HUGH MCMANUS: You
put three, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Then what will
now be the work in progress?
HUGH MCMANUS: The
work in progress
is whatever the person
next to you gives to you.
Because everybody's going to
pass them at the same time.
We're going to be very
formal about that.
We're going to have a
standard process where
we're going to ask everybody to
pass them all at the same time.
So then yeah, you'll just
have to look and see--
AUDIENCE: It's
actually what you have
left by the end of the round.
HUGH MCMANUS: That's right.
That's correct.
AUDIENCE: If you rolled a
3 and had four chips here,
you would move three, and you'd
take one left plus whatever
new stuff--
HUGH MCMANUS: Plus
whatever payment.
So it's whatever's
sitting on that mat
at the end of the round
is your work in progress.
So the average of a
six-sided die is 3 and 1/2,
so what do we think this system
should be able to do over--
we're going to do 20 rounds.
What do we think it should
be able to do over 20 rounds?
Is it going to
process 3 and 1/2?
Are these die rolls
going to even out?
Maybe.
Everyone's thinking.
AUDIENCE: 60?
HUGH MCMANUS: 60, so
that would be 3ish.
So it's not going to
be perfect, but it's
going to be close to evened out.
AUDIENCE: So we don't
process more than 3.
[INAUDIBLE]
HUGH MCMANUS: Yeah,
in the first round,
you're only going to get 3.
More will come in
as the customer
person rolls their dice.
The initiating person.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
You think less?
Less, OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Less than?
AUDIENCE: 35.
HUGH MCMANUS: Less than 35.
OK, you're thinking
a lot less, OK.
Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
OK.
So yeah, people are
struggling with this.
Intuitively, this is hard.
It's hard to figure out
what this thing should do.
I've already sort of
biased the conversation
by intimating that the
system's going to behave badly.
But one's intuition,
unfortunately,
about random systems is
that they should even out.
The way the human
brain works is badly
biased towards just figuring
random things will even out.
There's all sorts of
interesting gambling fallacies
that are almost hardwired
into people's brains.
The "law of averages"-- now,
there is no law of averages.
It tends that there is--
we'll see.
I won't go into that any deeper
than that because what we're
going to do, given that we can't
really figure it out a priori,
and if we try to do
statistics on it,
it actually gets really
complicated really fast,
we're going to do it, all right?
So let's go ahead
and do our process.
OK, what I'm going
to ask everybody
to do the first couple of
rounds is follow my cue.
I'm going to
dictate the process.
AUDIENCE: And we're
going to try to check
and make sure you're doing it.
HUGH MCMANUS: Right.
And our facilitators
will check and make
sure you're doing it right.
The first thing we do
is pick up the dice.
Everybody holding their dice?
OK, roll it.
OK, pick up that many chips,
or three if you only got three.
And now everybody together pass,
passing to the right, yeah.
This is a properly done--
actually, more or
less by accident,
properly done U-shaped cell.
We're passing to the
right, unless you're
left-handed, in which
case it's not so proper.
OK, everybody done that?
Now write down what you
did, how many did you pass?
OK, the customer person
has a slightly harder job.
Everybody figuring that out?
Yeah, OK.
So the only
communication necessary
should be the number of
chips finished, right?
All right, day two.
Everybody roll the dice.
Pick up that number of
dice or whatever you have,
and pass it to the right.
Write down your results.
The amount that was finished
needs to be communicated,
no other talking please.
And finally, day 10.
Not finally, but day 10.
Roll dice, pick up chips,
pass them to the right,
and write everything down.
Now we're going to pause and
ask how this process is doing.
Who has only one chip?
A couple of people
have only one chip.
Who has eight ships or more?
Eight or more.
10 or more?
Looks like we have a winner.
How many?
AUDIENCE: 14.
HUGH MCMANUS: 14 chips.
AUDIENCE: Just yesterday.
HUGH MCMANUS: That's right.
Yeah, 6's are good today.
So yeah, that's
the one difference.
So what should we do
about this process?
We've got at least
two people who
are keeping their in-bin clear.
They're sitting back, definitely
they have extra capacity.
Yeah, we've got at least one
person who just cannot keep up
and probably has to go, right?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So does that mean there's
a bottleneck there?
Must be, right?
No, of course not, she has the
same dice as everybody else.
This is a transparent--
this process is behaving badly
and is actually throwing out
bad clues about itself.
That looks like a bottleneck.
It isn't, it's just bad luck.
Some people look like
they're doing really well.
No, they're just lucky.
And let's see if
the trends continue.
Day 11, roll the dice,
pick up the chips,
pass them to the right,
write things down.
And 20.
Pick them up, hand them
along, write everything down.
OK, so how did that go?
Let's see, who has 14 or better?
See if we broke our old record.
Several people.
What have we got?
AUDIENCE: I got 15.
HUGH MCMANUS: 15.
What do we got here?
AUDIENCE: 13.
HUGH MCMANUS: 13, oh not quite.
So 15, we have a new winner.
How is our problem employee now?
AUDIENCE: A little bit
better, only at eight.
HUGH MCMANUS: Eight, OK.
Down to eight, so
magically got better.
How about our people
that had one before?
Anybody have one now?
We still got some
people with not so many.
I think we have one
repeat winner, do we not?
OK.
So there we go.
The system is, in fact,
behaving fairly badly.
We even had an unintended lesson
in failure of standard process,
right?
When we got off
standard process,
we also had some high
variability in the performance
of our process.
There's some
calculations you can
do they're self-explanatory.
We're going to give you
a few minutes to do that.
Only a few.
If you don't quite get them
finished, that's probably OK.
The one thing we would
really like to see
is the customer just getting
the average throughput.
That first average
for the customer
is an important
number because we
want to see what our
performance looks like.
Oh that's a new one.
OK, very good.
So you got 2.7 average
throughput on m1.
What's your average
throughput, 2.6?
OK.
Looks like people are
finishing up the numbers.
2.6, average 3.05.
2.3 and got another average?
Still working on it, OK.
What about utilizations?
What was our average utilization
at our first medical table?
AUDIENCE: 0.77
HUGH MCMANUS: 0.77, OK.
AUDIENCE: 0.74.
HUGH MCMANUS: Pardon?
HUGH MCMANUS: 0.74, OK.
AUDIENCE: 0.87.
HUGH MCMANUS: 0.87, OK.
We got a good one there.
AUDIENCE: 0.66.
HUGH MCMANUS: 0.66 2.8,
and what's the utilization?
AUDIENCE: 0.8.
HUGH MCMANUS: 0.8, OK.
So interesting thing here.
And we can look at some
of the other details.
Another thing, I just asked you
to look at your personal sheet
there.
Is there any strong
trend in the inventories?
Inventories were definitely
going up from 3 maybe.
Some of them were going down.
What's the overall
trend in inventory?
Anyone see a trend?
AUDIENCE: It went
up and stabilized.
HUGH MCMANUS: Went
up and stabilized?
AUDIENCE: Give or take.
HUGH MCMANUS: Give or take.
Went up and stabilized,
give or take.
AUDIENCE: Ours
just kept going up.
HUGH MCMANUS: Just
kept going up.
Went up?
OK.
That was even with three
people with only one?
AUDIENCE: The average
overall went up.
HUGH MCMANUS: The average
overall still went up,
that's interesting.
That's interesting.
And what was the personal
productivity, the utilization
factor, of, say, you, the one
who never had any inventory?
What was your
personal productivity?
AUDIENCE: 0.74.
HUGH MCMANUS: 0.74.
And what about the people
that had lots of inventory?
AUDIENCE: 0.68
HUGH MCMANUS: 0.68.
AUDIENCE: Utilization?
HUGH MCMANUS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 0.88.
HUGH MCMANUS: 0.88, OK.
So this person's
working very efficiently
but has lots of inventory.
This person is working
not very efficiently,
but has lots of inventory.
This person doesn't
have very much--
this system is
behaving very oddly.
It's behaving in ways that
are difficult to understand.
So why?
AUDIENCE: We're not always
passing the exact number
that we roll.
HUGH MCMANUS: We're
not always passing
the exact number we roll.
AUDIENCE: In a lower
average process [INAUDIBLE]..
HUGH MCMANUS: OK, so there's
some unused capacity, right?
You roll a 6, you only have one.
But the inventory's going up.
Is that problem
going to go away?
AUDIENCE: Eventually.
HUGH MCMANUS: Eventually.
Good answer.
I mean, we got at
the root of it.
It was also sort of a
system problem, right?
Which is OK, it's behaving
badly because of that,
which makes it behave worse
because your inventory is
unpredictable.
So even if there's
lots of inventory,
the chance that there
would be a low inventory
and you'd waste a
6 is still there.
It doesn't go away even
as the inventory comes up.
We don't know what's
going to happen
and things depend on each other.
The amount that you
have in inventory
depends on the person next
to you who's rolling dice.
Even if you're
doing great, if they
roll a whole string
of 1's, you've
got nothing to work with.
So even if you're rolling all
6's or precisely on 3 and 1/2,
you're still not being able
to perform because of the way
the system is hooked together.
And this is really the key--
every time anybody rolls a 6
and doesn't have enough
chips, that capacity is wasted
and it never comes back.
You can never get it back.
And that's where the
"law of averages" fails.
In mechanical engineering,
we call it a ratchet effect.
It can go one way, but
it can't go the other.
We can lose capacity,
we never get it back.
So that's why we're seeing
these lower utilizations even
though we did 20 rounds,
which you'd think
would be enough time
for things to even out.
OK, now we're going to
run a computer simulation.
The first thing
that any person when
confronted with tangled data
like this should think is we
need more data.
And in fact, we do.
Although as we will see
in this particular case,
even a very large amount
of data does not help us.
We're going to run a
computer simulation, which
does this little exercise
for 20, but then also 200
and something days.
Looks like this.
What's shown here is days and
this is the inventory level
at the different stations.
The notations here are of
the AP case, but again,
it's the same simulation
for the medical case--
the four stations, the
inventory at the four stations,
versus time.
There's a couple of
things down here.
This is our
processing capability.
This is the WIP that's on
the table, the total WIP.
This is the cycle time.
This is how long it
takes the average chip
to move through the system.
And this is just a
little luck thing
to just see if maybe
some of this variation
is just due to luck.
Maybe our average die
roll is better or worse,
but we're rolling
an awful lot of die,
so we do expect the actual
average of the die rolls
to kind of even out even if
the system itself doesn't.
OK, so first thing we can
notice about the system is OK,
we're running it 200 times.
Is it settling down?
It's not.
Just waiting for it to settle
down is not going to work.
And let's see, did
that do anything?
Oh, there we go.
Select that.
Boink, I just ran it again.
Came out different.
If I run it again, different.
Even the gross behavior of
the system is not predictable.
It doesn't like, get bigger
and then kind of even off.
If I ran it a billion
times and took the average,
I'd actually get sort
of a logarithmic curve
where it would go
up and steadily
flatten out, although never
actually reach an equilibrium.
But the behavior even
over a large number
of rounds of any given
instance of this system
is extremely unpredictable.
So perfect system
except for variability.
The variability is making
the system behave very badly.
OK, what can we do about this?
The other nice thing about
a computer simulation
is we can change
it relatively easy.
We could, for example, lower
the customer input variability.
That's a favorite
of bad processes.
People say, it's our
customer's fault.
There's too much customer
input variability.
Like all patients show up Friday
night, so it's not our fault.
Let's lower the customer
input variability some.
Didn't help very much.
Let's lower it a lot.
Why?
That appeared to
help a little bit.
Yeah, that's a little better.
That's with a lot less
customer input variability.
But basically, both count.
The process variability
and the customer input
variability count a lot.
Let's do this, though.
Let's lower the customer
demand just a little bit.
Oh, it looks about the same as
lowering the variability a lot.
Let's lower the
customer demand 20%.
Doesn't look great,
but what's changed?
It looks like there's a lot
less variability in the process.
And if we lower the
customer variability by 30%,
there's still variability,
but the system can handle it.
Essentially we're
destressing the system,
running it at a little bit
less than 100% capacity,
and it behaves a lot better.
And this was brought
up in the AP system
where they were running
at 100% capacity.
It's the same in this system.
Basically, if we try to stress
it, we only get about 70%.
If we say, you know, it's only
going to run at 70% anyway,
let's just give it
70% of the load.
It actually behaves pretty well.
This is a nonintuitive
effect unless you're
one of those workers.
What happens if you have
to work all the time
and something goes wrong?
Chaos, right?
Crap, I have to
stay up all night,
but I can't, I'm too tired,
so things just go to hell.
What happens if you
have six hours of work
in an eight-hour day and
something goes wrong?
You can fix it.
From an individual
worker's point of view,
this is very easy to understand.
The system effect seems
kind of mysterious,
but actually, if you think about
what's happening on the ground,
if the system is
not fully stressed,
it can handle variability.
And you don't have to back off
on the system all that much
to handle quite a
lot of variability.
Yeah, I understand that
we're tight on time.
We're coming to a
close here fortunately.
So that's kind of magic.
The other thing we can
do is attack variability,
and if we attack
variability heroically--
let's reduce variability
30% across the board--
it helps some.
Yeah, it's better, but it's
still behaving kind of badly.
If we reduce variability
70% across the board,
this is truly heroic
variability reduction.
That didn't work well.
Oh, there we go.
Notice when it was all but
one, it was still no good.
We have now reduced variability
heroically across the board,
we've got about the same level
of effect as reducing the--
so apparently, according to
the simulation, what we need
is either heroic variability
reduction or a modest decrease
in the load on the system.
And this is actually a very
powerful practical lesson
and it comes from
that same equation
that Earll was showing.
If we're mathematically
inclined here,
what happens when
our utilization
is very high on this term?
Just put a 1 in there and see
what happens mathematically.
It goes to infinity, right?
If the system is
completely loaded
and there's any
variability at all,
it will just continue to get
worse and worse in its behavior
if it's 100% loaded.
The variability was
actually squared,
so if we can reduce
variability, that's good,
but this effect is actually
even more powerful.
And if we plot the
two effects, here's
a plot of what happens
if we control variability
for various utilizations.
If we have a heavily loaded
system-- that's this one--
and we reduce
variability, once we've
driven it down really low--
this is the cue
time or inventory,
they're basically the same--
it will start to behave.
But if there's
noticeable variation
on a heavily loaded system,
it's going to behave badly.
If it's not so heavily loaded,
it almost doesn't matter.
This is a lightly loaded
system and the variability
doesn't matter, this is a
moderately loaded system
and reducing
variability is good.
And that's not really
linear, but basically,
sort of proportionally,
if we reduce variability,
we get better behavior.
But in a very heavily
loaded system,
we really have to drive it to 0.
This is Six Sigma.
If we have a system that we
want to load really heavily,
we want to make
billions of ICs, then
we have to drive the
variability very close to 0
to get the system to behave.
This is the converse thought.
If we ease off on utilization
for various variabilities,
what we see is that
blow-up effect,
that divided by 0 as
we get close to 1.
And it's almost independent
of the variability level.
At any level, if we back off
some from 100% utilization,
the behavior actually
gets a lot better.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering how
organizational management deals
with this fact if
they know that they
need to operate significantly
under their capacity--
HUGH MCMANUS: That's
a tough one, right?
AUDIENCE: --in order
to control their system
versus having a perfect
system without variation.
HUGH MCMANUS: That's right.
That's right.
Managers like Six Sigma because
if your system is perfect,
you can load it at 100%.
They want to hear that.
That's a message
they want to hear.
In systems like health
care or engineering,
getting the variability very,
very low is very, very hard.
And this is a very rich field.
In the interest
of time, I'm going
to jump to a couple
of useful tips.
One is that one of
the purposes of Lean,
and this was
actually illustrated
very nicely by
the AP case study,
is to free up those resources.
Not in order to lay people off
or necessarily save money even,
but if you can take 10% or 20%
of your non-value-added time
out of your day, what
does that get you?
That gets you that
headroom that allows
you to deal with variability.
And it's one of the sort of
root causes of why Lean seems
to have a magic effect
of increasing quality
and throughput time when that's
not even what you're aiming at.
If you just take
waste out of a system,
suddenly everybody in the system
has a little bit of extra time
to deal with variation, to
deal with things going wrong.
So that's sort of
the hint, number one.
The other thing is that in
terms of variability reduction,
although that's an art,
there's no one answer.
There are things
that help a lot.
Reducing something like
health care variability to 0
is obviously not even
possible, but one
of the things about
actually both health
care and engineering-type
processes
is that the distributions
aren't really normal.
It tends to be like, a
bunch of standard cases
and then some wacko ones.
Well, what happens
to the variability
in terms of those equations if
you just take the wacko ones
off the table?
Gets a lot better, right?
It gets a lot better.
So essentially, special case
handling for the outliers.
In the simulation
game, we originally
designed the health
care simulation
to be part of a three-day
seminar where you'd
play that last round at the
end, like after this lesson,
and there's something in there
called a patient advocate.
Anybody even look at that card?
What did it do?
AUDIENCE: It helped
those patients that
would take the most
amount of time and helped
shepherd them
through the system.
HUGH MCMANUS: Right, exactly.
In terms of the simulation,
it took the 6's off, right?
And if you looked at
the distributions,
they were highly non-standard.
The 6's were horrible.
And so that's actually
a real example
of taking the really difficult
cases out of the standard flow
of the system, and that
makes the standard flow
work a lot better.
Of course, you have to
devote some resources,
some special resources,
to the difficult people.
But there's ways you can
kind of knock the top off
of high variabilities that
can help a lot on that side.
On the capacity
side, the real key
is to use the benefits
of any kind of Lean
to essentially plow
them back into making
people's lives easier so they
have a little bit of extra time
to absorb the variability.